loin de ces squido je veux surtout
surtout ribas fit ian thomas bahc est un
jeu de combat qui se joue au tour par
tour vous voyez on a vingt secondes pour
choisir l'action d'un personnage en
cliquant sur ses articulations
dit comme ça ça l' hyper chiant mais en
réalité ça va c c'est juste voilà par
exemple on peut faire le foetus déjà
donc se dire que c'est un bon joueur
donc en fait le but du jeu c'est de
faire toucher le cul de l'adversaire au
sol et à la fin de la partie on revoit
donc l'action en temps réel comme ça
voilà j'ai tenté un truc
ah bon attention moi je suis gymnase je
suis un backflip hommes n'ont alors est
si je te l'avais mis en pleine tête
j'étais le héros de cette vidéo ouais
mais tu l'as pas fait même bien briser
des rêves comme ça c'est ça que tu aimes
dans la vie yann je suis rouge et ouaté
bleu là parce que je peux faire mal à ce
que je t'ai vu jeter passée gros orteil
mon gars c'est douloureux 1 j'ai perdu
voila voila j'ai mis le coup de pied le
plus bas possible quoi obtient la plus
vache creusé dans le sol ou quoi non
parce que vous risquez bien quand je me
bats contre toi c'est je te laisse faire
et puis on est vas-y cette fois chez le
rouge et je te des fours c'est ce qu'on
va voir ihany répond gentiment c'est ce
qu'on va voir
il est pas méchant dans ce qu'ils
répondent aux plats ça tu compares si
l'on regarde je vais pas mourir ici bas
tu sais quoi je vais faire la technique
regarde toi tu me regardes de oru tu me
prends de total me lumeya ne regarde
cette fois je contracte tout yann hop la
marianne ce qui se passe entre nous il
ya deux ans le truc de merde recul je me
relève au no way la mer je fais de la
merde je fais je fais un truc nul
regarde ça de moi ça doit s'épanouir
logiquement il se passe un truc de fou
j'ai gagné à la maison royale du coup de
genou quand même au couple à howie le
genou qui va monter nananana jérusalem
ont d'ailleurs ça va je vais faire un
saut yann je vais faire un saut je crois
oui je crois que tu pars son côté je
crois que j'ai ma place était en face de
moi ce serait tellement style et non
mais c'est quoi ce jeu mais [ __ ] ce
plongeon mais en face aurait été d'un
style regarde pendant une grosse droite
alors yade je suis le bleu tué le rouge
hop il ya sarah claque et ça va claquer
aaa
au porte parole je suis ultra dans la
merde ça paye pour ça va être beau non
on y regarde regarde je panique jan
je lance une jambe je me suis super bien
maintenant je me relève c'est ce qu'on
va voir oh non vincent duthoit regard je
t'écrase la tête
alalala touré qu a donc la tour et fès à
aa
non mais il peut tout j'ai découvert un
endroit qui s'appelle le pectoraux
qu'est incroyable voyage et perth blanc
battant superbe aux eaux au nom qui va
tomber en premier au revoir
tu te contredis quoi parce que c'est ok
je montre que je fais je montre que je
suis aussi devra annoncer mal très mal à
bien j'aimerais faire un petit saut non
ça suffira pas attention oh oui oh tu es
folle le sceau de lâche rien mais qui a
rejoint yann jeu contre moi bref je
crois je défonce base y abat regarde
l'air froid je défonce le mec qui passe
sa vie sur ce jeu bordel mais regarde
moi voler comme une merde il est 10e dan
ceinture noire j'aurais pu contrôler mon
perso il est paralysé
mais j'y gagne vas-y je te colle mon
poulain sofiane est à gauche et son
ennemi est à droite
j'ai fait une connerie j'ai fait une
connerie c'est bien au bac qui a fait
gaffe ils préparent un coup violent au
niveau du genou et une cloche je me
réjouis vraiment qui va te faire un truc
de malade
oh [ __ ] t'as ta il va tous les sons du
lâche au le mec va perdre mais tes mails
en équilibre sur ces mots nathan mais
comment il fait là il me fait un caprice
mais ça c'est pas possible
ce gars est incroyable attend à leur ex
responsable sur ces mots là mais je suis
outré j'avais mis mal moi je suis pas
sûr on a tâté mal très mal je suis ultra
val tuer
ceinture jaune contre une ceinture noire
bravo l'équilibrage arômes tu as mis une
gauche il se dégage du charisme il va
toucher le sol est en moi regarde
[Musique]
j'ai peur cette intrigue style et si on
va dire regardez moi ça m'amènera
normalement tel un personnage est
carrément mort non non non non il te
réceptionner les bouteilles les muscles
et les vertèbres hockey rupture des
cervicales alors il est musclé des
cervicales morts non non non il est
musclé du mollah là mais non pas sa
place à la petite claque légère légère
du doigt de la main comme ça après et
comment c'est impressionnant ce combat
au petit dos de la main et je sais pas
ça parce que c'est moi hallett a perdu
il ya des reculs hop la veille âge
battant mais j'étais quand même tapé le
pin up la battant au plat attends tu
veut pas de toi encore là maintenant
encore up la [ __ ] faut que j'arrive à
faire le saut du lunch
j'arrive à pas oh j'ai trouvé c'est le
sceau du lhc est un peu style est debout
et aux [ __ ] sous l'aisselle
olalala l'or ça s'appelle le coût du
déodorant au le coût du stic
avec peut-être une droite peut-être pas
du tout avec une parfaite égalité savage
aulas suis dans la merde je suis plus eu
encore plus que toi oh là là je suis mal
oh oui battue parisienne des services
offerts dans son sillage son regard non
non c'est pas vrai j'étais attention le
syndidat je tente le tout pour le tout
au nom de dieu pied nul on en fait une
dernière celui qu'elles aient gagné là
tout gagné la finale ultime de toribash
aujourd'hui ou au plus tard c'est pas
bon non et adjet devait alors soit on
reste là dessus et on est aussi fort
d'un claude soit en reste là dessus à
deux questions yann j'aurai ta tête sur
un pic
je suis prêt je tente la jambe droite
baum a bien joué le combat des champions
celui qui reste devant lui la balle au
centre et y arrive plus à parler le
printemps qui tombe il a perdu av
non j'ai pas y aller mais non
oh
bon bah yann merci d'avoir joué à temps
mais de tuer ton forum c'est moi quoi
âge exact est joué ben on le saura à
merde tu as quitté tôt mais oui je
tentera de jouer alors que les élevages
aussi afin de cette vidéo avec yann
surtout ribadu me l'avait conseillé
hyper nombreuses boucle romande fois
c'est pas français
merci à yann de d'avoir bad est venu
pour prendre ça branlait finalement mais
dans la salle fait plaisir de te branler
westergaard nst file de cette affluence
autour très bientôt dans une prochaine
vidéo que tout le monde
pissas au bye bye urines
[Musique]